I want to tell you now about
a country
that many fear may be the next
in Vladimir Putin's sights.
Indeed, on Friday,
Secretary of State Blinken expressed
deep concern about Russian plots
to destabilize the government there.
It's a small, poor nation
just to the southwest of Ukraine
that holds within it
a Russian backed separatists region
The nation I'm speaking of is Moldova
and it happens to be my birthpla
So what in the world is going on
Let's bring in Moldovan journali
Paula, Arizona, to explain.
Paula, it's great to see you.
Welcome to the program.
So let's give our audience
a sense of what's happened in
just the past few weeks.
Last week, President Zelensky pr
some intelligence and shared evi
with the Moldovan president, Mai
Of an attempted
Russian plot
to for a coup
to overthrow the government ther
Just this past weekend, she
she gave more evidence
and said that was indeed the cas
She described it as a hybrid war
aimed to destabilize society.
Can you give us any more insight
what's happening?
Yes.
So President my Asanda mentioned
the plot would involve people
with military preparation,
some of them coming from abroad
in order to provoke violence
and to break into state institut
and take hostages
during opposition protests here
Also, Zelensky's adviser Mikhail
confirmed this kind of the detai
saying that actually Russia's
new plan
for Moldova does not involve tan
but bandits. By this,
he meant
the kind of leader of the opposi
of the pro-Kremlin party.
Sure.
Ellen Schroeder,
who stands accused for money
laundering in Moldova
and has therefore fled for Israe
But meanwhile, he
his party in Moldova
is organizing mass protests.
We just had one today, and he ap
video live streaming
during these protests.
What makes this even more concer
we should note,
is that
the Moldovan government,
the current government,
is a pro-Western government
Do we know if this coup attempt
has been thwarted successfully?
Well, state institutions
over the past week
have talked about not allowing a
60 foreign citizens into the cou
Some of them, they said,
had forged papers
with like
different names
and different nationalities
and
more police have been patrolling
the streets
and the kind of Ministry
of Internal Affairs released
these kind of plan for
bomb shelters
in case of any kind of emergency
So it does
feel like
state institutions have intensif
both their actions
and their communication,
which has been poor in the past.
Russia has become
a candidate for EU state,
and they Moldova has become a ca
for EU status.
That having been said, it's
a very vulnerable country.
It's a very poor country.
I believe its military
defense budget is just around
$80 million a year
and I know
that has led to a lot of interna
as well and economic challenges.
Inflation is about 27%.
What is a bigger threat?
Is it
the domestic issues
regarding the economy,
or is it the external
threat perhaps for Moscow?
Well, the two are interlinked.
So at the moment of course
people are more concerned with t
to day economic struggles.
But at the same time
the kind of pro-Kremlin
opposition is trying to capitali
on these economic issues.
They are asking the government t
100% of the winter bills and so
And obviously
if a pro-Europe government in Mo
was replaced with a pro-Kremlin
then Moldova would be used in th
against Ukraine.
By Russia, because obviously we
Transnistria in the east,
a breakaway region where 1500
Russian troops are stationed
and with 20,000
tons of
ammunition, soviet-era
ammunition is still stored.
And to this point,
Russia is still providing
Moldova with gas in about 70%
of electricity
comes from that breakaway
region, Transnistria,
that pro-Russian region as well.
I know
Western allies have been quick
to come to Moldova's
defense and provide more aid.
Is it enough to get Moldova
to finally leave Russia's grasp
and perhaps join EU
so foreign aid has
been helpful
in compensating people's
bills this winter,
but they weren't compensated up
to the 100%
that protesters today were deman
And
the government is
saying that they want to invest
in more green energy and diversi
our gas and electricity kind of
But inflation at the moment is s
the highest in Europe
and people are struggling
to pay their mortgages,
to pay their bills
and to kind of cover their basic
and people that I've spoken to
have said that
they're thinking of emigrating.
We already have a problem with
very few kind of human resources
a big diaspora
that is looking for more economi
opportunities outside Moldova, i
Is there any concern, as Russia
has launched
its new offensive,
that it could take
military action against Moldova?
I know her
there had been fear of that
early on in the war
I'm sorry, could you repeat that
Is there any concern
now, as Russia has launched
a new offensive
in Ukraine,
that it could make
any sort of military attempt at
There had been concern
of that early on in the war.
Yeah, there's a saying in Moldov
that we depend on Odessa
and Odessa depends on Nikolayev
but we also have the South,
and that is vulnerable.
And so far, Moldova has been pro
by the Ukrainian army.
And the fact
that the Ukrainian army managed
to move the front line for the W
has kind of appeased spirits.
In Moldova,
people have become calmer as a r
But obviously we were following
the situation closely and
and hope for the best.
We have a large number of Ukrain
refugees here in Moldova,
and you know, to them
there is an obvious difference b
Ukraine and Moldova at the momen
But still people are anxious.